rien ne lui échappe à 300 kilomètres à
la ronde ce nouveau radar inauguré le 8
septembre à palaiseau servira à guider
les avions civils en région parisienne
une structure indispensable qui couvre
la moitié du territoire français ça va
au niveau des vosges ça va au niveau de
bresse pratiquement au sud c'est ça va
du côté de limoges pratiquement donc au
nord
ça dépasse largement la france ce radar
voit les avions l'ensemble des avions
qui a dans le ciel et diffuse les images
de ses avions sur des écrans qui sont
situés devant les contrôleurs et donc
les contrôleurs peuvent guider les
avions sur des routes aériennes du haut
d'une tour de 66 mètres de haut il
permettra de guider les avions jusqu aux
aéroports d'orly et roissy charles de
gaulle
au-delà de l'aspect pratique ce projet
symbolise aussi le rapprochement entre
les yvelines et l'essonne
ça rentre dans cette logique du
développement du cluster paris saclay
qui est yvelines essonne donc le cluster
se développe sur trois grands sites jir
le sud du plateau de saclay là dans
l'est dans l'essonne sur palaiseau orsay
et gif mais aussi sur billancourt
puisque c'est très fortement lié aux
activités économiques de recherche qui
assure sur les yvelines et aussi à
satory un développement qui n'est pas du
goût de tous quelques manifestants se
sont rassemblés pour protester contre
l'urbanisation du plateau de saclay la
construction du radar a coûté 8 millions
d'euros 800 avions pourront être
traitées simultanément